- All right, before we go,
(audience applauding)
I wanna share one last happy story.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(jazz music)
Okay, so y'all can walk
down any Manhattan street
and you're sure to find
vendors hawking hotdogs, tacos,
halal food, like, all those NYC staples.
Then there's this truck.
That bright pink vision
is the Candy Zoo truck
opened up by three New
York mamas last year.
And it may be even more popular
with grownups than with kids.
I would love it.
We have the owners on
the line now watching
on NBC-4 New York.
Say hi to Tina, Jen and Karen, everybody.
(audience cheering and applauding)
What's up ladies?
So I have to ask like,
how did this get started?
And I'd love everything behind you.
- Thank you!
- Thank you so much.
Well, Jen is my oldest friend.
Our grandparents were friends,
our parents were friends, we're friends.
We always wanted to do something together.
We weren't really quite
sure what that would be.
But coming out of the pandemic,
we knew it had to be something happy.
- So here we are.
Candy.
We figured candy was the way to go.
And our twosome became a threesome.
We brought in Tina as a partner,
and we bought a 1997 used
truck, and we had it fabricated.
And here we are.
This is our Candy Zoo truck.
- Oh, I love it.
And I love that you'll
also work, is it true,
with Ronald McDonald House?
- That's right.
We partner with the Ronald McDonald House
to donate candy to all the children
with pediatric cancer and their families
'cause we wanna bring some
happiness and joy into their life
and let them come up to the truck,
and they get to choose
their selections of candy.
And it's the one thing that at least
they get to choose for themselves
since during the day they
have all these appointments
that they can't, you know, not go to,
and they have no control over that.
So it's really nice to
be able to give back
and see their smiling faces.
- Oh, you're bringing
so much joy to people.
Thank you so much, ladies,
for joining us today.
This is awesome.
I'm liking your post right now.
All right?
(bell dinging)
- [All] Thank you!
- Absolutely.
And that is not all.
Our season long partner Pilot pen,
makers of FriXion, the
go-to erasable pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to celebrate those
fearlessly following their dreams,
just like y'all.
So they're gonna be writing a check
to the Ronald McDonald House
of New York on your behalf for-
(all exclaiming)
- Thank you so much!
(audience applauding)
- Thank you so much, ladies!
And thank you to all our guests this hour.
Eric McCormack, Jenna
Lyons, Nzingha Prescod,
Julia, Amy, and Grace Potter.
Y'all have a great day.
And if it's not, well, try and change it.
(upbeat music)